[Música]
i
bueno antes de empezar quiero agradecer
a todas las personas que están presentes
aquí también a la organización por
invitarnos y esperemos que hayan
disfrutado de las demás charlas para los
que no nos conocen
somos jorge y nacho
jorge la son dos hermanitos posta de
años estaba por decir dos chicos lindos
pero de chico no temo nada porque
estamos bastante grandecitos yo tengo 28
años y él tiene un bastante y este del
24 y también de lindo no tenemos nada
así que solamente somos dos hermanos
posadeños me encantan la pinta que
teníamos en ese entonces nada que de la
remera dentro del pantalón citó de las
medias hasta casilla no para la rodilla
típica moda de los 90 vuelo y pelados s
bueno desde chico siempre nos gustaban
las mismas cosas
es compartíamos lo mismo gusto ya sea
por el fútbol somos del mismo equipo
somos del más grande e independiente
independiente lo trabaje boca
roger
no hay nadie en la pendiente parece
bueno también teníamos lo mismo gusto
por la música nos gustaba mucho la
música y siempre tuvimos los mismos
gustos para nosotros desde siempre gustó
la cumbia siempre
de cumbias a bandera con un velo con
[Aplausos]
me gusta pero bueno también nos gustaban
cuestiones como en realidad nos gustaba
a todos juntos siempre hacíamos todos
juntos en cualquier momento siempre no
nos despegamos incluso para ir al baño
lo íbamos juntos sin decirles la verdad
un poco de privacidad bueno estuvimos y
los primero años juntos y de la mano
bueno siempre hacemos todo juntos y es
ahí donde descubrimos que podríamos en
el 2006 hace bastante nosotros compramos
nuestro primer celular que era ahora ya
no existe más y en ese entonces
grabamos todos los momentos que
compartíamos juntos y descubrimos que
ahí a partir de la oración de los vídeos
podríamos inmortalizar a aquellos lindos
momentos y la parte de ahí decidimos
crear contenido con un celular bastante
simple y nosotros siempre me gustó el
humor siempre me gustó hacer reír a los
demás siempre éramos los payasos del
grupo y por esa razón de 2006 con una
camarita de un simple celular
grabamos vídeos humorísticos que era
bastante básicos para ese entonces
los inicios de jorge y nachito
siempre a nosotros fuimos los payasos
del grupo como dijo jorge siempre que
queríamos hacer reír a la gente y
principalmente a nuestro círculo de
amigos en el barrio no siempre quisimos
hacer payasadas para hacerle reír a
todos pero siempre fue con nuestro
círculo de amigos siempre grabamos
vídeos para después mostrarles a ellos
si criticaban de la risa y si pues fue
con chiste internos siempre fue todo
entre nosotros porque si venía otra
persona de otro lado y veía esos vídeos
obviamente no había entender lo que
estamos diciendo porque eran todos
chistes internos
bueno con respecto a los recursos que
utilizamos en aquel entonces teníamos un
editor de vídeos que se llama windows
movie maker ese típico ese típico editor
de vídeos básico que se usa en los 15
por ejemplo que por ejemplo está la
quinceañera así y saludando y sale un
corazón y ahí aparece la foto de la
familia y demás entonces era ese es el
editor de imagen es el editor de vídeos
tan básicos que nosotros ni siquiera
teníamos acceso a internet en el set en
ese entonces y lo que teníamos que hacer
era
toquetear como nosotros decimos acá para
aprender el programa no entonces pasa un
tiempo ya en el 2008 pudimos tener
acceso a internet no y ahí si podíamos
buscar a un poco de tutoriales aprender
de otros programas pero en ese entonces
ésta tampoco teníamos la mentalidad para
para hacer vídeos para que la gente
pueda ver y pueda difundir los vídeos
simplemente queríamos guardar
y almacenar esos vídeos que teníamos
para que no ocurra ningún formateo con
la computadora porque al principio
nosotros teníamos una computadora muy
viejita muy precaria que tuvo muchos
problemas y pues por la culpa de esa de
esa computadora que que se formatea a
cada rato para dimos muchos vídeos
viejos y bueno para ese para eso
hacíamos para eso utilizamos la
plataforma de youtube en aquel entonces
en 2008 solamente para almacenar los
vídeos y no para las para su difusión
serían
también tuvimos nuestra primera cámara
fue la primera inversión que hicimos en
el canal porque como jorge dijo al
principio utilizamos celulares durante
mucho tiempo tuvimos celulares solares y
después quisimos comprar una camarita
que en ese entonces era con unas pilas
que era muy vieja pero se veía mucho
mejor que los solares
bueno ahí son los primeros vídeos es el
tema número del año 2008 2008 2009 si
aumentamos de peso si estoy gordo a ir a
un palito era joven era una tablita
fíjate ahí era un chavalín bueno ahora
ya estamos grandes bueno es un vídeo que
grabamos con la primera cámara que
tuvimos y ya quiero que pase esto bueno
el primer público bueno recién en el año
2009 nosotros comprendimos que youtube
era una plataforma para difundir lo que
podríamos hacer en ese entonces
como ya dije descubrimos que no
solamente nuestros amigos podrían ver
nuestras creaciones sino que nos fuimos
hacia otro enfoque para transmitir
nuestros vídeos y que entiendan nuestros
nuestros chistes que hacíamos los vídeos
por esa razón dejamos de lado solamente
hacer reír a nuestros amigos a nosotros
a nuestro círculo a nuestra familia sino
pensando siempre en un público que te
mira más general de aci da poquito a
poquito empezaron a aparecer personas
que no conocíamos de diferentes partes
del país primero y uno se daba cuenta a
partir de los comentarios que venían de
a poquito más personas pero recién en el
año 2012 después de mucho vídeo de humor
tratamos de implementar algo nuevo en el
canal una nueva sección que eran las
coreografías de temas de la movida
tropical que estaba sonando en ese
entonces si bien ya existían personas
que bailaban temas solamente conoce los
wachiturros conocer o no o son muy
chiquitos 2011-2012
entonces nosotros decidimos crear
coreografías propias bailando los temas
que estaba de moda en ese entonces que
era el nuevo estilo de cumbia y de baile
se podría decir que bailar estos temas
fue como un impulso para hacer conocer
nuestro canal y además difundir todos
nuestros nuestros otros tipos de
contenidos que era el humor también
hacemos retos y muchos vídeos también
siempre referido al humor por esa razón
notamos que fue una ola bastante grande
porque nuestro canal creció rápidamente
en ese año y vinieron personas y
personas que nos comentaban que eran de
diferentes partes del país países
vecinos e incluso países alejado de ala
hispana como méxico y españa es así como
nosotros continuamos con las geografías
a partir de ese entonces pero nunca
dejamos de lado de nuestra nueva pasión
era los vídeos humorísticos
el primero de baile fue el vídeo más
visto de no tocar al yo a más de 30
millones
gracias
los primeros vídeos eran dentro de
nuestra casa y el resto era en
diferentes lugares de la costanera pero
también para difundir un poco esta
hermosa ciudad
bueno you tube un trabajo
hasta ese entonces nosotros hacíamos
hace muchos años que veníamos haciendo
vídeos pero se puede decir que estamos
haciendo vídeos por el amor por amor el
arte no básicamente estuvimos
aproximadamente cinco años haciendo
vídeos totalmente por hobby porque nos
encanta porque nos divierte de hecho
hasta hoy en día lo hacemos y nos
encanta es como un escape que tenemos
cuando no estamos estudiando cuando
estamos aburridos nos empezamos
empezamos a hacer vídeos o empezamos a
pensar ideas nuevas y es lo que nos
gusta realmente
pasa el tiempo y recibimos un correo por
parte de youtube que nos invita a que
formamos parte de la comunidad de
partners eso significa que son los
socios
para poder ganar dinero por medio de la
publicidad que pone en nuestros vídeos
esto de una forma simple en youtube si
se pone en contacto con las marcas o
mejor dicho las marcas se ponen en
contacto con youtube y quieren poner
publicidad en los vídeos de los
creadores que somos nosotros los
youtubers solo es influenciar o como
quieran llamar
de esa manera youtube se lleva un
porcentaje y nosotros un porcentaje ahí
es cuando nos dimos cuenta que empezamos
a trabajar de eso porque ella ya pasó a
hacer de un hobby a un trabajo más que
cuando el canal sigue creciendo cuando
va en crecimiento la gente lo que hace
es demandar más vídeos
si antes subíamos un vídeo cada dos
semanas ahí empezamos a subir cada dos
días cada tres días cada cuatro días
pero ahí es cuando se ha convertido en
un trabajo no
y ahí empezaron las inversiones porque
cuando nosotros empezamos a cobrar las
las primeras veces lo primero que
hicimos es invertir en el canal para que
lo espectadores tengan aún mejor
contenido para que se vea mejor
compramos un micrófono para que se
escuche mejor logramos más iluminación
un trípode una mejor cámara y obviamente
la computadora no puede faltar porque
sigamos teniendo como computadoras que
se formatean cada cinco segundos y que
la parte más importante porque una
persona al estar expuesta públicamente
es su vivo que aparecen las críticas
tanto críticas malas como buenas las
críticas buenas serían las constructivas
que nosotros a leal lo aceptamos pero
también están aquellas aquellos
comentarios por ejemplo que son más
hacia el lado del insulto es obvio que
cuando una persona está expuesta siempre
aparecen hagas lo que hagas
esto me hace recordar a una vez cuando
estuvimos de acuerdo en que la lazio en
abrasivas 2003 2014 cuando estuvimos
estuvimos grabando estuvimos grabando
una coreografía en la costanera de
posadas y en el momento que estamos
grabando pasa en frente de nosotros una
camioneta y un tipo de la ventana orita
agarren una pala pues la verdad entonces
fue algo que no hizo detener la
grabación agarramos todo y nos fuimos
una ferretería compro la pala
nosotros hicimos oídos sordos y seguimos
con lo nuestro porque hay que ignorar
porque nosotros este momento estamos
bailando porque los bailes eran todos
todo seguido y no había edición
prácticamente nos vino a interrumpir
entonces
un aplauso para el señor quiero dijo que
agarramos la pala
[Aplausos]
así que espero que ustedes entre todas
las personas
y lo mismo ocurre con las redes sociales
siempre aparece en aquellos malos
comentarios pero nosotros hoy en día ya
estamos acostumbrados porque si bien los
hay son la minoría entonces por esa
razón ya sea a cualquier cualquier
trabajo que uno tenga cualquier sueño
hay que luchar sin importar las críticas
y las piedras que se presentan en el
camino bueno ahí vamos a los logros como
nuestro canal
siempre ha estado en crecimiento desde a
partir de las coreos obviamente nos
llegaron muchos propuestas también para
hacer shows en vivo
no solamente de bailes tampoco de
solamente de monólogos sino también con
las parodias seguramente muchos de
ustedes lo que están presente sabrán lo
que son las parodias pero tal vez
algunos no voy a contarles un poquito de
lo que se trata básicamente es agarrar
un tema musical le voy a poner un
ejemplo que que nosotros tenemos en
nuestro canal se acuerdan el tema
despacito de diane que es el bueno s
nosotros agarramos el sistema musical y
le cambiamos la letra le hicimos en vez
de despacito le hicimos fer necesitó lo
hicimos entonces eso a la gente le
desagrada ver cómo le cambiamos la letra
y lo transformamos en algo humorístico
no entonces gracias a eso pudimos
y en muchas partes del país y muchas
partes de nuestra provincia misiones
también para hacer sobre envíos y la
verdad que eso es algo es algo muy lindo
para también como experiencia ahí por
ejemplo podemos ver dos ejemplos de
coches humorísticos que hacemos de
historias que podemos inventarnos en la
cabeza y lo plasmamos en un vídeo
siempre con humor siempre eso estuvo
desde el primer día y también ahí
podemos ver dos clases de parodias
arriba está jorge haciéndose el button y
abajo estoy yo haciéndome el mal humano
osuna osuna perdón me parecía
por otro lado en cuanto a los logros
también hicimos logramos cosas
personales cosas que son muy importantes
para nosotros como por ejemplo llegar a
la meta de 100 mil seguidores allá por
el 2015 mucho tiempo estuvimos vidas
gracias a hacer gracias en serio
mucho tiempo estuvimos haciendo vídeos y
sin darnos cuenta que estamos llegando a
esa meta y para nosotros los youtubers
es algo muy importante llegar a esa
cifra porque youtube premia a nosotros
los creadores con con este cuadro
hermoso que tenemos que se llama la
placa de la placa de plata la verdad que
miro ese cuadro y me encantan los no sé
si son más lindos los chicos que tienen
la placa o la placa misma pero la
mentira la placa y hermosa lo tenemos
ahí colgado en el living de nuestra casa
la verdad que es un logro
sinceramente nos sentimos como algo que
como no sé un logro personal por ejemplo
si uno va a una competencia de algún
deporte y gana llega al podio y le dan
esa medalla nosotros tenemos así como
algo como un trofeo que nosotros hemos
ahora que estoy viendo eso me acuerdo de
una anécdota de una chica que fue a
entrevistarnos en nuestra casa que vio
la placa y nos felicitó porque llegamos
a 100 seguidores y ella de modo de
chiste nos dice bueno ahora vamos por el
millón y con jorge nos miramos y nos
reímos porque para nosotros era un sueño
que prácticamente no nos vamos a poder
cumplir porque tantos años están tantos
años llegar a 100 mil seguidores y
imagínate llegar a un millón que son
diez veces más
era algo prácticamente imposible que no
nos imaginamos llegar pasó el tiempo y
llegamos en el año 2017 el año pasado
diciembre del 2007 en donde llegamos en
ese momento ahí está mi cara a las 5 de
la mañana
no levantamos
[Aplausos]
nos levantamos a las 5 de la mañana
porque sabíamos que quedaba muy poco
tiempo y más o menos a esta hora
llegamos al millón y nos levantamos esta
hora para hacer esta historia sí y por
suerte no sabíamos de inmortalizar este
momento así podemos compartir con
ustedes ese momento donde donde el
contador subió llevarle un millón de
señores y bueno la verdad que fue un
sueño ya cumplido nosotros creemos que
ya estamos satisfechos estamos ya
logramos lo que lo que más anhelamos que
ya llegar al millón obviamente que vamos
a seguir con esto porque nos apasiona
pero ver esa cifra ya ya estamos hechos
ahí está la plaga
ahí está la placa del millón y bueno
también es casos
y ahí pueden ver la cara de sorprendido
de los otros dos al recibir la placa
bueno además de todo lo que dijo nacho
creemos que el mayor logro que tuvimos
durante todo este tiempo fue el contacto
con los seguidores ya sea tanto en las
redes sociales como kara kara es tanta
la emoción que uno siente ya sea a
través de un simple mensaje privado
algún comentario o por ejemplo durante
todo este tiempo nosotros tuvimos la
posibilidad de conocer a muchos
seguidores
personalmente en algún evento ya sea
cruzando cuando nos cruzamos por la
calle o también cuando van a nuestra
casa a golpearnos de fiesta entonces es
una emoción inexplicable porque no
solamente son números son computadoras
que por así decirlo nos ven sino que son
personas de carne y hueso y al estar en
contacto con ellos nos trasmite una
emoción bastante grande
voy a contar una pequeña anécdota que
ocurrió el año hace dos años más o menos
en tecnópolis cuando fuimos a buenos
aires el cual era un evento bastante
grande que había muchos influencias
influencias muchos youtubers y un día
teníamos una entrevista no estamos solos
estamos junto a un youtuber bastante
popular bastante conocido llamado luso
que ahora vaya mejorando senado el
espanyol luso es bastante conocido
y justo antes de empezar a la entrevista
aparece un chico corriendo llorando de
emoción más o menos unos diez años y
viene y nos abraza los dos y no sé
cuántos minutos estuvimos pero no
pudimos empezar rápidamente la
entrevista porque el chico lloraba
amargamente así desde emoción y la
verdad no nos sorprendimos demasiado era
la primera vez que nos pasaba que un
chico lloraba por nosotros volver a
estos dos boludos
y si la verdad fue algo muy emocionante
también porque vino corriendo hacia
nosotros y no hacia un youtuber que era
bastante desconocido en ese entonces y
nos dimos cuenta que era muy fanático de
nosotros y fue algo bastante bastante
hermoso
justamente
el 16 de septiembre de nuestro canal
cumple 10 años y hemos logrado a partir
en todo este tiempo hemos logrado muchas
cosas a pesar de todas las piedras que
se presentaban en el camino con mucho
esfuerzo mucha dedicación siempre le
metimos fichan por así decirlo a esto
que realmente nos apasiona que es hacer
vídeos humorísticos y también sin dejar
de lado los estudios yo por ejemplo soy
técnico de comunicación social y me
falta un paso para llegar al licenciado
y él por ejemplo es analista de sistema
que también está bastante avanzado
entonces es lindo trabajar de algo que
realmente te gusta porque te sentís
cómodo
por esa razón hay que seguir hay que
luchar para para una meta y tener
siempre claro esa meta y sobre todo
nunca te rindas
muchas gracias gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]